my friend asked that in the present
World scenario Muslim growing beard
prone to more suspection further he said
that uh this was the same with the six
during 15 20 years back now it is
opposite to us I couldn't answer to
this the brother posed the question that
in today's world if a Muslim grows a
beard he's prone for more suspicion for
what suspicion that he's a true Muslim
and I want to be a true Muslim so
someone says that I have grown a beard
and I'm following Islam I'm
fundamentalist I'm a fundamentalist a
fundamentalist is the person who follows
the fundamental of any particular
subject and if you hear my answer which
I've given in many of my talks that a
person has to be a good doctor and you
say that if he puts a cross he's prone
for suspicion to become a doctor good
alhamdulillah so doctor to prove himself
a doctor he'll put a cross on his car oh
don't put a cross on the car because
that means you're prone for being
suspicion that you're a doctor so doctor
is proud to be a doctor therefore he
puts a Dr in front of his name similarly
me byow a beard I'm proud to be a Muslim
I want to identify being a Muslim but I
know that the media today is Ming Islam
they're picking up some black sheep of a
community and they're portraying them as
though they're merciless people that
they are terrorists what we have to do
we have to grow a beard wear a cap and
prove to them this Muslim is here who's
honest who's not a terrorist we don't
terrorize innocent people so so you say
okay this has become a bad label the
beard on the cap now I will prove I will
keep a beard why because the prophet
said that our beloved Prophet wasam said
it's mentioned inkari volume number
seven Hadith number 780 and 81 that
pleased with him he said that the
prophet said that do the opposite of
what the pagans did TR your must and
grow your beard it's the Commandment of
the Prophet we do it it's a label we are
proud to identify as Muslims believe me
I have this beard on this cap I have
Trav throughout the world alhamdulillah
going to America also even after 911
going to UK G to Australia going to
Canada name the country most of the
Western countries have been there
and I'm happy that they suspect me the
moment they suspect me I have
opportunity for doing
da Dr do you believe in Jihad I said yes
I believe in Jihad even Jesus Christ
peace be open believed in Jad Jad means
to strive and Struggle No No Dr n do you
believe in fighting I said Jesus believe
in fighting he said take a SW and go and
fight in the Book of Numbers in the
Gospel of Luke so this way it gives me
an opportunity
I don't want to do the same thing other
you been problem you should know your
stuff very well so the thing is that
even when I went to USA and customs and
immigration they ask me question and I
like it I
said I'm happy so with this beard it
gives me chance to do more da so more
chance for me to go to Jenna correct
because I know my stuff very well
alhamdulillah I know my religion well
I'm a practicing Muslim why should I be
afraid so then they have ah tonight good
Muslims at least now the view of Muslims
have changed a little bit whether 2% 5%
10% 90% depends upon how well you
speak so you tell me one thing can this
beard even h a
fly so suspension of what this cap can
it harm anyone no I've given the talk on
if the label shows your intent where it
and I've given various logical proofs
Etc why a person should we a cap and
Port beard logical and Islamic reason
hope that answer the question